what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch ourselves superman and lois
episode four today been loving this
series so far
can't wait i saw this go trending
yesterday on twitter and i was really
happy for it obviously didn't look at
what was trending specifically other
than superman lois so i'm really happy
this show is getting the
the recognition it deserves guys this is
reaction highlights full length ratchet
and watch along where you sync up with
the time code we'll be over at our
patreon page we're over there we got the
option for reaction highlights and watch
alongs for
many many many shows thank you to
everyone who's shown your support so far
snyder cut full length watch along will
be over there this weekend
along with starting a falcon and winter
soldier so we've got we got even more
coming in store baby got even more last
thing got to thank prothom
jindal for editing these reaction
highlights for us he's edits for people
like jaby kawai from time to time and
now he started editing for us and it's
been fun
us going back and forth figuring out how
to edit for us
because we're different it's an art form
us for all the hard work you're doing
follow him on youtube let's get into
this
[Music]
i went there six years ago funny enough
huh
you shot some of this
what's that hans zimmer like music oh
yeah
man established a precedent break
that edge what are you
up to
now the resurrection begins excuse me
what are you up to
just being a good person helping the
town out morgan edge is
at the football game he really cares
about smallville
the town votes tomorrow on whether to
grant him mining right so he's visiting
all the spots letting everyone see him
as this man of the people and pretending
like he's actually going to pump money
into this area well they really pack him
in here huh
dad i know it's a surprise but it's
john's home opener
can't yes coach not you no not you
the other one oh jack yes coach i need
you to get me that ball
you hear me let's go
just use your powers it'll be fine
i guess it's the discipline of not using
his powers as it has to do
yeah which will make him even better at
football
nice dude look at that look at that
yeah recover that fumble
yeah yeah this is a great football game
yeah
[Applause]
i was like watching a football movie
yeah jordan yeah rudy
okay jonathan just be happy for him
that's all you gotta do is be happy
don't be jealous or upset at all george
jonathan
just be happy for jordan increasingly no
matter how terrible things get for you
hmm he's suspicious it's gonna be really
awkward if crime goes down during a game
though
how could you not tell what that he's
good at football he's not
the kent family needs to fly under the
radar my sons need to live their lives
dad clark and i can handle this look we
appreciate your concern we really do
there's an armored nut job on the loose
who wants you dead and your priority
seems to be coaching my sons
yes the military is terrified of you
crime groups like intergang are already
planning an uptick of activity yeah
dude no
penitentiary why because if superman's
not around
the site is more vulnerable ah jesus
they're moving thaddeus kilgrave psycho
genius who got radicalized off hating
you
what could go wrong we'll be there but
i'm not throwing away time with my
family for a
show of good faith let me get my bag
from the car
stick around this weekend maybe it'll be
easier if i pitch in
that's good he just wants to hang out
with the family be supportive
i picked up on the right tone the real
character shift
yeah but it reads like a debate with the
first grader
the mayor keeps saying jobs then you
fire off a list of epa infractions
this is exactly why i hired you i even
did my own copy editing
that part still needed some work where
your old contract
for your lawyer we're aware of the piece
you intend to publish tomorrow
how could you know that any such action
would be in breach of your previous
contract as i'm sure your lawyer will
explain
jesus how do they know about them
does morgan itch have kryptonian spies
[Music]
here's the check from the last episode
i can't believe this happened stupid
broken arm
oh no oh dude no
whoa
what what is happening to me you're
gonna be able to compete with jordan
yeah that's what's happening to you
[Laughter]
absolutely is it's actually a great shot
i don't know that's really fair to any
of the players to be honest you just
suggested
the last episode taking over the whole
team there's room for you to step up
clark just get better
like how jordan just got better stop
being jealous
take inspiration from your brother a
tiny favor to ask
i was thinking that since my article was
shredded and i can't technically speak
out about morgan edge
the next best thing would be to have
smallville's favorite son
show up and say some words on behalf of
justice now if you'll excuse me i just
found out edge is at the mines if you
wait i can go with you
no i got it you have practice i can
handle myself so much for lois lane's
big expose huh
told us she had nothing on edge right
now seems pretty clear to me that that's
morgan edge bringing jobs in
every line this guy has
have you come to take a tour of our
facilities look i'm kind of bored with
the whole faux british accent
billionaire at a football game trying to
fit in
conjunct lois
i was raised who cares
[Laughter]
oh she's badass actually i have one more
ace to play
bring it with me to the town assembly
maybe we can talk more then
yeah i wish i played poker so i could
understand those references they were
saying about aces and stuff
[Laughter]
see it's plays like these that make me
want to quit coaching all together and
open up the pizzeria
oh you think that's funny harris you
know what you could have caught that
pass
had you not gone to that keg party and
busted up your arm
that's how he busted up his arm the keg
party
fun this game is 20
physical 80 mental
why would why would you let him stay
general lane
i need your sit rep on kilgrave go
einstein saw time as an illusion oh no
one that gets us to wear a watch oh i
love this actor
oh what's his name you might remember it
but i love this actor
see the thing is that's not chewing gum
it's a temperature
sensitive synthetic polymer resin i made
in the sink of my prison cell
highly mercurial at an atomic level
combined with the precise vibration of
a making mission impossible gum
three one
yeah that was really cool
all right he's moving like a speedster
yeah
fine just just touching myself man
nowhere i'll be out there
just touch it and take a [ __ ] to just
everything
he just he just did a dwayne johnson
prisoner kilgray thaddeus r highest
possible threat level
yeah something's wrong
oh man clark's got three problems to
deal with right now
this is very bad
seriously just tell your dad on me what
happened to your cats
it's driving me crazy so tore it off hey
i'm i'm sorry
look whatever my arm's killing me
bishop said please respond priority
alpha
oh this poor kid this is rough
yeah bishop six we've got a hit on
kilgray
oh man sorry having to bounce both of
these shits
it's so rough so rough
i think i'll kill graveyard if you were
a coach in football
maybe you would have found it trying to
have a life and everything
i'm sorry for the changes you're having
to endure i know that you're
showing signs of being special given
that your dad is the most important
force for good in the entire world that
means you have an obligation too
don't waste his time
try to think about the fact that when
your dad gets distracted
lives are at stake jesus christ wow man
you are helping right now the morgan
edge made a lot of promises
he kept every single one of them so i'll
say what are we waiting for let's sign
this motion
and get those minds going yeah so
one-sided it's pathetic
hey where are you you're literally my
last shot at presenting my side of this
you know i would do it myself but i'm
trying not to get bankrupted in a
lawsuit hurry
oh man he can't balance
so much she's got to deal with it's got
like a peter parker's thing going on
this episode
peter clarker do you want to grab a
drink tonight i mean
no kids no husbands just a girl's night
out i promise you
it'll be fun all in favor go cheat on
your husbands
exclusive rights to the schuster mines
all opposed nay oh
stepping up motion approved
what time do you want to meet e babe
i am so so sorry i missed the vote i
know it's okay
no it's not i just want to apologize and
i want you to know that
babe i don't need an excuse i know you
have an excuse you're superman
close okay fine i'm mad and i know it's
irrational because i
understand that there were lives at
stake but this was so
important to me and we lost the vote by
the way and now i'm feeling guilty for
wanting you to do something you said you
would do
oh wow this is so good it feels like i'm
really
far down on your list of priorities oh
yeah right now in this moment that i
might regret tomorrow
[Laughter]
i think the writers have been therapy or
something
something about the communication in
this show it was so good
it's like the gray side of all this i
love it
earthquake hands i'm sorry i'll fix it
you can't afford a burger how are you
going to pay for some nice ass furniture
hey hey what's going on damn this dude
is really
bullied yeah seriously
what's going on i don't know i'll go
check on it
oh this pork head how poor is this kid
he's so poor he's so poor he just gets
ridiculed for it all the time
that place he was earlier that wasn't
even his own home
he's broke into someone else's home
where's kilgray
he just said to get you here dude this
sonic glass would work
i needed you in closer range let me show
you what this baby can do
you need to use the elt okay i think i
did this to him the bonfire the party i
think my heat vision caused an explosion
and it affected him somehow
okay well look you can run really later
grandpa said that's too busy saving the
world look he's not the only one that
can do this
oh my god
i am the captain now
oh no oh guys glitching like a
freaking j-horror movie yeah i know oh
my god
we need to get out of here now we need
that
so much is happening it's the worst day
happy clark can't
yes
oh no
whoa wow see how i did this joel
your heat vision caused a blast but
there was another material present
yellow phosphorescence we think that may
have triggered the boy's metahuman
development
says that he's gonna go to a special
school for kids with these sorts of
abilities uh-oh wait there's a special
school for kids of powers
how many of these kids are there that's
classified but let's just say
let's just say it's in the high
why didn't you 50s me the minute you
knew something was wrong
i may have misspoke misspoke you cannot
tell the boys not to come to me for help
this is the same toxic honor above all
else
crap you used to pull on me when i was a
kid lois please this isn't about us
no it's about you and your parents of
choices and how they
sucked then and they still suck i made a
choice to dedicate my life to the armed
servants you could have done both
that's what clark is doing and i see him
struggle with it
every day so how dare you tell him
he can't be the father he is because you
never bothered to give it a go
oh damn
that luther guy was right
i'm gonna go find him right now why
would dad need my help with the
harvester
mom can you stop being an investigative
reporter for just one second
surprised he set up a date night
yay
[Music]
i was thinking about all of those date
nights that i've missed
and i thought we could play a little
ketchup
oh dude you romantic you you
you [ __ ] car you made me all sappy
very good standing with me right now if
you play your cards right
there may even be a massage in it for
you see now you're just spoiling me
well you deserve to be spoiled to know
beyond any doubt
no matter what's going on what i'm up
against
this my time with you it's what gets me
through everything else
my first thought of the day and my last
thought at night
i love you
oh you've got to be kidding me hey sam
clark sorry to intrude there's a
situation in malawi not a priority yet
but my guess is it will be within the
hour i was calling lois
so she can fill you in you can decide
for yourself
she just went to the restroom but i
appreciate the heads up
i will let him know you called damn go
i'll be fast i promise i'll be waiting
hey i love you too
he was lying
we now earn the rights to this land
which holds enough
ex kryptonite resurrecting army assuming
they can find enough willingness
oh no oh fudge
so he's like building kryptonite slaves
yeah freetonian slaves
just have his own yeah a little coterie
of kryptonians
how cool what a motor sinister plant
i love that that's so messed up
all right great episode man yeah clark
is a romance
i'm really hooked into this i really am
very very hooked
i don't know where to begin well things
look like they're panning out well for
jordan on the football
team let's get that out of the way the
thing that panned out the best across
this whole episode that was the best all
right he's doing fine
so far right now i'm i look i felt like
i had
reasons to be concerned i put out a
pinned comment post on the last video if
you guys want to read i want to
in charge of any old argument right now
i was like okay i feel like i'm being
misunderstood
on my concern here my worry with him
being on the football team
not that i was completely against it but
i had
a worry and a concern as to why but as
it stands
looks like the show is taking the
direction where this is panning out
great for him right now him being
happier having less anxiety maybe it has
something specifically to do with sarah
maybe it has something to do with being
on the football team maybe it's both
either way it was actually really
refreshing to get an episode here with
jordan where he
you know he had a worry at one point
when that guy
tag was displaying powers and he was
concerned that he was responsible for it
that worries seemed to be valid
considering that looks like he was in
part
responsible for the metahuman evolution
of this tag character right
so i i actually liked that with jordan
it was not it was really refreshing to
actually get an
episode where he seems like pretty
positive for me you know
it was refreshing i like the growth of
his character and then of course
jonathan's learning how to adjust to
just being
a support like it's such a tough
physician for jonathan to be in
absolutely how to just be a supportive
ass brother
even though like every once in a while
whether it's through looks whether
saying something to
his dad saying something to tag yeah
there's always a little bit of something
coming out of him where
you could see there's there's resentment
and bitterness building and he's trying
not to let it get to him it's only human
and i feel like that's kind of like a
great way to describe
a lot of the discussions that this show
has um
with its characters i'm not talking
about like what political themes i'm
talking about
what characters they have here yeah well
yeah it's like super character driven
and that's what's so lovely about it i
think is because throughout this episode
and even the previous ones i feel like
we were both sitting here going damn
it's actually a really well communicated
scene and really well
sort of intended uh opening up of yeah
the subtext of the characters themselves
and what they're going through just the
way the show articulates those things
whether they be
uh in the world of jordan and jonathan
like i love that whole little thing they
discuss about like yeah he's not used to
being on the outside of the social
bubble and so he's trying to find his
way around that now
and i like that it's not super black and
white with him it's like yeah jonathan
is clearly not an
alpha in this dynamic anymore but he can
kind of get around the party and
whatever but
even between clark and and lois you know
in their moments like before even the
dinner scene at the end when they're
just having that
conversation in the front room of their
house about how clark couldn't show up
he's busy you know in metropolis and all
that like those were really tender and
very human moments that didn't feel like
they were obligatory because we need to
check in with the characters before
moving on like they really felt natural
within the context well this whole
episode was
mainly revolving around clark having to
balance all this
without being overly like as an audience
we can pick up on that this is a lot
he's having to balance he's being pulled
in every direction
and we don't need a scene that focuses
solely in on clark being like i'm having
a hard time
this is difficult yeah we never get that
scene even though
we can see it like especially by the
time he arrives at the um
the freaking oh the diff he's
dod the part department yeah d-o-d d-o-v
he is with the d-o-d
and when he shows up there you could
just see in tyler's performance
as a superman just like look i'm here at
a courtesy
this is my responsibility no idea
difficult the past 24 hours
yeah so i'm doing my best right now man
him not showing up for the meeting with
morgan edge and then
the conversation with lois i really love
that the way that was formed because
lois could easily be put in the position
in that given scene
that a lot of tv wives get thrown into
where you're just like god you're
annoying and you're harping on his ass
man you're understanding like
you see it happen all the way to
breaking bad
with the crystal meth cooking husband
and people are like get off walters back
lady
could easily it's so easy for her to get
a heart it's a thankless role in a lot
of ways it can be
but i love the reason the therapy lies
because it was like literally
uncovering every layer i thought in the
dialogue that i loved so much of
her being like look i no no i'm fine
seriously i'm fine i'm fine
okay look i get it you're superman and i
feel like this is irrational like you
can feel it's just so human to be like i
get it i understand i really do
underneath all this i also have like my
own personal feelings and i'm trying not
to get
in the way of a logical thought process
but this is an emotional thing for me
and it's it's different i'm trying not
to put myself like that's so
relatable and that's so human versus
just larger than life context
but we've all been in that situation i
think in our lives where it's like we
might feel
completely different than what our you
know logical brain is telling us to
think and feel about something
and then for her to even be like in the
moment of how i feel that i might regret
tomorrow
yeah this is how i feel that way that's
so true yeah someone says i'm like
this is my irrational view i wanted to
have this conversation right now so
right now here's how i like yeah
i regret something i'm saying right now
but you know like i thought it was so
so well done and then to be to end it on
the
note because one thing i'll say about
the cw shows as much as this stands out
in terms of how it's executed for being
like cable quality
or cinematic quality uh in certain
moments every one of these cw shows i've
i have not seen any of batwoman but what
can i attest to
all i've seen from the other ones is
they always have such a big heart
and that heart can sometimes be
incredibly corny and incredibly cheesy
but it still gets to my heart like i
still am moved
by it no matter how cheesy it is and
here
that's what that final moment reminded
me of it wasn't cheesy at all to me it
wasn't corny at all
how it was done here but when they do
get to that romantic element of bringing
you back to lois and clark
and like him having a date night and
showing like look i'm really doing my
best and i i'm trying to show that i
really do care
that heart is such a big part of what
makes a lot of these cw shows work
generally and i loved it being on
display here that was such a sweet scene
and
so actually my favorite scenes in here
are those two that we just talked about
yeah specifically involving
our title characters you know lois and
clark and having a balance
being superman amidst all this there's
so many interesting
things we're weaving around like even in
the conversation with lana
and uh kyle kyle
and kyle it was going down such a tropey
route
at first i feel like most tv shows would
have done this with the way morgan edge
was coming on
semi-aggressively i'm not aggressive but
you could tell that something was up
forward yeah and he's all his body
language in a kind of an attraction
level like
the way he communicates to her and i
feel like most tv shows which is where i
thought they were going
would be kyle's support of memorial edge
suddenly
it looks like morgan edge is flirting
with lana
and he would either get mad at lana or
morgan edge for
this flirtatious behavior that's usually
where shows go
99 of the time and then they had this
different more realistic flipperoo
of like look kyle this is not about you
yeah this is about how uncomfortable
i was made to feel it doesn't matter if
you thought he was flirting or not he
was making me uncomfortable
this is what was really happening and
you didn't seem to care about that
because you were only stuck in the
opportunist mentality of let's get ahead
i
thought that was such a richly later
argument to have
it like i'm like this is so different
than i expected it to go
especially to reflect on him like that
gave his character uh
yeah well it helped to pin that scene at
the very end too where they do have a
little
like a little bit of a tender moment you
know as a family which is mostly just
between the two of them because the kids
think it's
strange but yeah i liked at least
getting a little bit of a human
expansion on their situation together
and the scene even between
lana and lois i thought was a nice one
too like this one had a lot of
character scenes that are sticking out
just as shiny and bright as you know
some of the cool action moments and
stuff that we got too because like i
loved watching him
square off against kilgrave and like the
whole intro to kilgrave was really cool
who is that actor i mean i don't like
like
guys some people missed the first the
episode that we covered we have not
seen any of supergirl i've only seen her
in all the
crossovers and stuff so i don't know if
this thaddeus
kilgrave guy has appeared to other stuff
but the way he's treated kind of looks
like he has
brendan fletcher is that the guy who i'm
thinking of let me make sure that's him
yeah yeah brendan fletcher has his name
so we've seen him on like goosebumps uh
supernatural
he's an arrow he's a he is an arrow uh
quite a few episodes if i'm not mistaken
and freddie versus jonathan he's done so
much he's a character actor yeah
and he's great here freaking fantastic i
can't remember his name at the time but
yeah freaking fantastic actor like even
the way that that scene was executed
like we've seen that scene before
guy in prison and then one of those
types of armored vehicles
and then there's some plan that he has
you know he's gonna make quick work of
these guys
not gonna be a problem give a monologue
before it explodes out of there yeah
yeah give his like perfectly timed
monologue but then um
the way it was shot is what made it feel
so unique like yes great performance on
his end on the delivery of that
monologue
but i love that we don't see the
explosion yeah it's a budget saver
b it actually makes it cooler not to see
it yeah
because now we're the cool guy not
looking at the explosion collectively as
an audience
yeah i know it's just a different way to
capture the perspective especially with
how you cut to the people already being
taken out you know his squad who was
helping him that was already on the go
like
as opposed to watching all that happen
you know doing the tire track thing
using a bunch of b-roll from a bunch of
already shot actions too have done this
exact maneuver
yeah it was different the character with
um
sam though he's frustrating all the ways
i think the show wants you to be
frustrated by him
yeah like he's a military dad yes he's a
hardcore
military father so everything that he
does
feels like yes this is what this guy
would
be like those would be his priorities
and concerns
these are his priorities i love how it
can relate back to the way
lois felt she was being raised by him
like like yes
you might be dealing with superman and i
wasn't superman but this conversation is
very similar to all the things i heard
growing up yeah like it's back to that
mentality and
it's like he's looking at this 7743
project
thingy luther gave him that was like
apparently on
luther's world they were buddies yeah
and uh superman was evil right i know
he's got it kind of in his mind right
now of like what if there was superman
became a threat
i'm like right now clark has done
literally nothing
other than standing up for himself in
personal life matters that
have now made you like who's really turn
against him in a lot of ways
but it's like having that just in the
back of your head i feel like this show
has a good
sort of psychology focus around their
character so
it's like even though what clark is
doing is not
anything evil when you already have that
planet in your head you start
looking for the things where you're like
is this a sidon
your mind just starts irrationally going
down that path and with someone in his
position
who kind of just views clark as
not just a human being but like as the
ultimate most necessary
human weapon we have yeah you are just
on call
at all times because that's what you're
here for it's like function
yeah being like the military doesn't
trust you i'm the one who's trusting you
you know like having that attitude and
then feeling like
cornered out by your own family and like
all the blame
i think it's actually a richly layered
thing as opposed to misunderstanding
things that you're like oh my superman
being evil you know like yeah
stupid things but having this personal
connection and using
a lot of those to make him turn against
superman slowly
is actually a really neat way to go
about it makes makes the turn feel
personal oh yeah he's a character for
whom their comfort zone must dictate
that he has to be thinking ahead and
running all the possibilities and
whatnot and yeah like at least some kind
of contingency especially when it seems
like there's a wedge being driven
at least between him and the you know
kent
you know even if it's not like an
animosity thing it still is a conflict
that could easily grow so yeah it's like
i understand why he would at least
entertain the idea because it seems like
he's losing his grip on clark one way or
the other
my feelings are about it are subject to
change we'll see how that show
progresses then of course i'm morgan
edge i love
lois investigating i love the scene that
she had with morgan edge just like cut
past the [ __ ]
yeah like it just kept cutting him off i
don't care where you're from it wasn't
even just one line i'm like let's cut it
let's get to the chase you know
it's like she just kept interrupting and
being like i don't care
no don't try to pleasant talk stop it's
not gonna work yeah it's neat how it's
all correlating
why morgan edge is here and i'm sure
there might be
something with the arrival of clark kent
in smallville that might be linked to
whatever minefield of being able to
create
evil super soldier kryptonians are
linked in there but yeah i mean my guess
was that kryptonian lady was spying
on their conversation that's how she was
able to step in and be like i know what
you wrote or broken or something like
that you know
like using kryptonians at your disposal
is a pretty neat
threat yeah because you've got
surveillance capability and
every other kind of physical destructive
capability
and opening up the mines which is what
kyle's been like pushing for to get
everyone jobs
is he a firefighter yeah but but opening
up the mining work
it's neat how it's all tying together it
felt like for a while there was like
very specific plot going on smallville
morgan edge
all that and then you have superman's
random adventures but it's all but not
wanting to see how the whole luther
thing really ties in because
the first two episodes were about him as
the main villain so
now i'm like we've spent two episodes
not with him yeah
and now i wanna i'm looking to see how
it ties back into him now
i'm feeling like there's going to be
some sort of unlikely team up if he
knows how to kill kryptonians and
there's a kryptonian army
coming down the pike like that could be
a cool surprise later on this season
would be that's actually not a bad call
not hurt
johnny you heard get ready to cut back
to this moment
um yeah not a bad call and this whole
thing with tag too
poor guy yeah why does he gotta be so
poor yeah man
why are you so poor guys why are you so
poor you can't afford anything you poro
apparently everyone's working out feels
so rich destitute
if you're poor everyone's going to talk
about how broke you were yeah
everything you do they're going to link
it back to that in some way shape or
form
jerry you suck at football you're poor
if you have more money you'd be better
at football
like damn like you're rubbing this guy's
financial situation in his face he's a
teenager
isn't it half the town struggling out of
work like jesus you're like
one hell cheaper a specific thing
um but yeah i mean they weren't exactly
clear what his powers were but it looked
like some type of speedster ability
absolutely like with his phasing and
twitching the zipping around just
couldn't handle the control of his
powers
that was a beautiful moment clark does
show up to pick him up
yeah yeah oh god guys what'd you think
about this episode
leave your thoughts down for superman
and lois in the comment boxes this was
grand
really i'm loving this show subscribe
click that notification bell what did we
not talk about that we should have
talked about you know how these go
hit that like button and let's also
shout out some people who are pledged to
our daily takes mountain scenes
rewards here they get it they get a name
caller let's do this
chili lemon maiden azar
hussein pseudonymous entity olivia
delgade
jpq stevens t magic
infinity john byers
barres sorry kevin casimiro
casimiro differently saying adam
goldstein
nash kelly hales
jacob gonzalez levitt oh dell
josh barnes shawn davis oscar
moscool the jedi bro lauren
american horse peter pacheco joanna
saint louis and matthew men sing you are
part of the first half
of honorary rejects to be getting this
shout out thank you so much for being
part of our patreon page
hopefully you watch at least one thing
there a month anyhow
thanks for you for your support thanks
you for your so thank you thank you
thank you for being here okay best